face aux caméras le ministre des
affaires étrangères iranien et son
homologue chinois wang y signe un texte
qui entérine leur coopération
stratégique pour les 25 prochaines
années
un accord qui marque l'aboutissement de
négociations entamées lors de la visite
du président chinois à téhéran janvier
2016 si son contenu n'a pas été dévoilé
la diplomatie iranienne évoque des
causes politiques stratégiques et
économiques pour les dirigeants de la
république islamique
ce compromis concrétise le soutien
affiché par la chine à leur pays
nous remercions la chine pour ses
positions et actions appréciable en ces
temps de sanction cruelle contre l'iran
la chine est un ami des temps d'épreuve
pékin doit continuer d'être un
partenaire commercial majeur avec l'iran
et je souhaite plus de coopération dans
le domaine des coentreprises
cet accord s'inscrit aussi dans le vaste
projet chinois d'idées nouvelle route de
la soie la création de routes
commerciales avec plus de 130 pays
premier partenaire économique de téhéran
pékin était aussi l'un des principaux
acheteurs de pétrole iranien avant le
rétablissement des sanctions américaines
contre le secteur énergétique de la
république islamique sous l'impulsion de
donald trump
les etats unis se sont retirés de
l'accord international sur le nucléaire
iranien conclure 2015 avec les grandes
puissances
un retrait unilatéral américain qui a
entraîné la reprise graduelle par
téhéran de son programme
d'enrichissement de l'uranium
dans ce contexte cet accord avec la
chine devrait revigorer une économie
iranienne encore asphyxiés
mais ce soutien chinois ne sera pas
suffisant sans allègement des sanctions
américaines
les autorités iraniennes attend
désormais une reprise des négociations
avec l'administration de joe biden